- This episode of "LegalEagle"
was made possible by Skillshare.
With the passing of Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
President Trump was able
to nominate and appoint
his third Supreme Court
justice, Amy Coney Barrett.
This rankled many Democrats
because the process took place
right before the 2020 election
and under COVID circumstances.
And the process included a
COVID superspreader event
at the White House.
But they accused President Trump
and Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
of rank hypocrisy, given
that the Republican Senate
refused to hold a hearing
on President Obama's
pick for Supreme Court,
Merrick Garland,
who was nominated 237 days
before the 2016 election.
- I think it's safe to say
there will not be hearings or votes.
I think it is also safe to say
the next president, whoever that may be,
is gonna be the person who chooses
the next Supreme Court justice.
- This appointment of Amy Coney
Barrett to the Supreme Court
represents a large shift
in ideology on the Court
and some Democrats are
calling for retribution.
And this has caused some to suggest
that if President Biden
is able to take control of the Senate,
he should engage in what's
called court packing.
If the Democrats are able to take Georgia,
they could conceivably
have the votes to do it.
And the thing is, there's nothing special
about the number of justices
on the Supreme Court.
We didn't arrive at that
number by divine intervention
and it's not in the Constitution.
So that raises the question,
would it in fact be legal
to just simply expand the Supreme Court
if the Democrats take the Senate?
Can the party simply add
justices to the Supreme Court
and then fill those vacancies?
What happened the last time
a president tried to pack the Court?
And are there any other limits
that can be imposed on the
members of the Supreme Court?
(regal orchestral music)
Hey Legal Eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because the future of the Supreme Court
is actually at stake.
You might recall that two years ago,
Marco Rubio introduced a
Constitutional amendment
limiting the Supreme Court
to nine justices forever.
He said, "There's nothing
magical about the number nine.
"It's not inherently right
"just because the number of
seats on the Supreme Court
"remains unchanged since 1869,
"but there is something
inherently good and important
"about preventing the
further destabilization
"of essential institutions."
So is Senator Rubio correct
that in order to limits
on the Supreme Court
we'd actually need a
Constitutional amendment?
Well, it depends on what kind of limits
you're talking about.
And to understand the Supreme Court,
we have to understand what's
called the Judiciary Act
and of course the US Constitution.
The Constitution mandates
that there be a chief justice.
Article I, Section III, Clause
6 refers to a chief justice,
quote, "Who shall preside
over the impeachment trial
"of the President of the United States."
But beyond that, the
Constitution is silent
as to how many justices actually
have to be on the Court.
In theory, the Constitution
allows for just two justices,
or 11, 23, or 41.
It doesn't say that there
is an optimal number
and that's for Congress to decide.
Article III, Section 1 of the Constitution
gives Congress broad discretion
to establish the court system.
Quote, "The judicial
Power of the United States
"shall be vested in one Supreme Court,
"and in such inferior
Courts as the Congress
"may from time to time
ordain and establish."
Now Article III does not
provide how many justices
will still on this Supreme Court.
That was to be hashed out politically
by the earliest members of
Congress and the president.
We typically call these
folks the Founding Fathers
to give them extra gravitas,
but at the end of the day,
they were just the earliest
politicians in this country.
They made some brilliant decisions
and some boneheaded ones,
and that's what happens when
you're inventing a new country.
And the Judiciary Act of 1789
established the first Supreme
Court with six justices.
The country was so small that
the Supreme Court justices,
quote, "Rode the circuit,"
hearing cases in the
regional circuit courts
as well as the cases
before the Supreme Court.
But in 1801, President John Adams
and a lame duck Federalist Congress
passed the Judiciary Act of 1801
which actually reduced
the number of justices
on the Court to five.
The goal was to stop incoming president
Thomas Jefferson's Court appointments.
Jefferson and his Democratic Republicans
quickly repealed the act,
putting the Court back to six justices.
But President Jefferson wasn't convinced
that six was the right number of justices
for the Supreme Court either
and in 1807, Jefferson and Congress
agreed to expand the Court,
adding a seventh justice
when Congress added a
seventh federal circuit.
The ideal being that as
the country gets bigger,
you need more federal
circuits and thus more judges
are needed for the Supreme Court as well.
And the next amendment to
the Judiciary Act in 1837
followed this same principle.
President Andrew Jackson
added two additional justices
after Congress expanded
the number of federal
circuit courts again.
And the next big amendment
to the Judiciary Act
was during the Civil War
when Congress created
the 10th circuit in 1863.
At this point, the Supreme
Court had 10 justices,
but in 1866, after the war,
Congress passed legislation
to gradually reduce the
Court to seven justices.
This happened for two reasons.
First, Republicans were
redrawing the geographical lines
for the judicial circuits, going
back down to nine circuits.
So why not nine justices then?
Well, because of the second point.
They wanted to limit the influence
of the former Confederate states.
There'd been a tradition
of appointing a judge from each circuit,
so each circuit had a justice
who could also hear circuit cases.
But this meant that between 1837 and 1862
five of the nine circuits
comprised exclusively Slave states.
So former Confederates still
had a disproportionate impact
on who was on the Supreme Court
watching out for their interest.
But the 1866 acts left only two circuits
that comprised of only former Slave states
and only one that comprised
only former Confederate states.
But as you learn from history,
Democrats fought
Reconstruction tooth and nail
and three years later a new Judiciary Act
put the number back to nine justices.
The Judiciary Act of 1869 said,
"Be it enacted by the Senate
and House of Representatives
"of the United States
in Congress assembled,
"that the Supreme Court
of the United States
"shall here and after consist
"of the Chief Justice of the United States
"and eight associate justices,
"any six of whom shall
constitute a quorum;
"and for the purposes of this act
"there shall be appointed
"an additional associate
justice of said court."
So that more or less brings us up to date
with the Judiciary in 2020.
The number of Supreme Court justices
has remained at nine since 1869.
And there are currently 12
regional federal circuits
organized from the 94
US judicial districts
and there's a 13th circuit
that's called the Federal Circuit
which has nationwide
jurisdiction over certain appeals
based on subject matter.
And, obviously, the US has done away
with the custom that there
should be one justice
for each of the judicial circuits,
otherwise we would have
four additional justices.
But let's pause here and think back
to Senator Rubio's proposal
that there should be nine justices
on the Supreme Court forever.
Why would that be?
Well, for comparison purposes,
consider other common law countries.
The Supreme Court of the
United Kingdom has 12 members.
Australia's highest court has seven.
Canada's has nine.
Does this really tell us anything
about the fairness of the institutions?
We could, of course,
make this a numbers game,
but that's not really what this all about.
Supreme Court battles
are all about ideology.
Whose views are represented
and what are the judicial philosophies
of the different justices,
and how does a judge tend to
rule about a particular issue?
As much as both sides try
to stand on principle,
the Court battles are mainly about power
and this is just as true now
as it historically has been over time.
And for comparison's sake,
the population of the US back in 1869
was almost 39 million people.
The population in the US in 2010
was over 300 million people.
You could argue that a
nation of 300 million people
needs a bigger Supreme Court
to adequately represent
everyone's interests.
And many countries in Europe ensure
that the courts have justices
representing all sides of
the political spectrum.
So given this logic, the rising population
and the fact that there is no requirement
that the number of justices
on the Supreme Court stay at nine,
and of course the tit-for-tat nature
of adding more justices in retribution
for what happened to Merrick Garland,
some people have argued that
the next Democratic president
should simply add justices
to the Supreme Court,
something that's called court packing.
Now many of you might be familiar
with the term court packing
from your school days.
Because President Biden won't be the first
to wrestle with the idea of court packing.
And what most people remember
is that FDR tried to add six
justices to the Supreme Court,
but that's not quite the whole story.
In the midst of the Great Depression,
Roosevelt had proposed a
number of laws and regulations
to stop the economic meltdown
and to provide welfare to Americans.
Generally these are referred
to as FDR's New Deal.
But the Supreme Court overturned
a number of FDR's New Deal programs
on the basis that they
were unconstitutional,
saying generally that Congress
simply didn't have the power
to pass these kinds of
economic regulations
because they didn't have the power
under the Constitution's Commerce clause.
And FDR particularly disagreed
with the decision the
Supreme Court made in 1935
in Schechter Poultry
Corp. versus United States
which struck down a part
of the National Industrial Recovery Act.
And given that the Supreme Court
had said these laws were unconstitutional,
there was nothing that Congress
or the president could do.
They lacked the power.
It wasn't available
under the Constitution.
So in retaliation,
Roosevelt suggested
expanding the membership
of the Supreme Court.
The law would've added one
justice to the Supreme Court
for every justice over the age of 70,
with a maximum of six additional justices.
The idea being that he
would pack the Court
with justices who agreed with his ideology
and his interpretation of the Constitution
that would allow Congress
and the president
to pass the New Deal legislation.
But after public outcry,
the law to expand the Supreme
Court did not in fact pass.
But interestingly, the Supreme Court
did take a more favorable
view of New Deal legislation
in allowing much of it to stand.
And since that time,
it obviated the request
for more people to join the Supreme Court
and FDR's attempt to pack the courts
has been portrayed as a
power grab ever since.
But there's an additional
dimension to FDR's plan
that often doesn't get recognition.
It actually doesn't add,
necessarily, six justices.
It would've simply added one justice
for every sitting justice
over the age of 70
up to a maximum of six,
ensuring that you would
never fall below nine,
even if the older judges died or retired.
In part, FDR's plan was addressing
the lifetime tenue of
Supreme Court judgeships.
Life terms for Supreme Court justices
has always been controversial.
But in 1789, at the time
of the first Constitutional Convention,
life expectancy was 34 years old.
But 2011, life expectancy
was 78 years old.
Is this a problem for the Supreme Court?
Well, that depends on who you ask.
At times, Congress passed legislation
to nudge judges towards retirement.
Several Republican Congresses in the 1860s
provided full salaries and benefits
to all federal judges who retired.
This worked and Republicans
were able to fill
several formerly Democratic
seats on the Judiciary.
In 1932, Herbert Hoover
enacted austerity measures
during the Depression.
One of them was cutting
Supreme Court justices
retirement salaries in half.
According to research by Judge Glock,
Herbert Hoover's attorney general warned
that the law meant justices will, quote,
"Hang on like grim death
"until the Angel Gabriel blows the horn."
He was, of course, correct.
Once the bill passed,
nobody wanted to retire.
FDR recognized this
and attempted to restore their
full retirement salaries,
but the bill failed.
And that was actually part
of FDR's court packing plan as well.
The legislation would've restored
the justices' full pensions.
Judge Glock's research on this matter
found records in FDR's library,
in the papers of his attorney
general, Homer Cummings,
demonstrating that the
Court expansion plan
was modeled on what
Republicans did in the 1960s.
And in 1937, Congress did, in fact,
restore the full pensions
for retiring justices
and one justice actually retired.
Now, critics of court packing point out
some extremely obvious
flaws with the idea.
The first of which is that court packing
isn't really a permanent solution.
Since this isn't codified
in the Constitution itself,
if the norm of a nine justice
Supreme Court is violated,
then effectively any
time a political party
takes control of the House,
the Senate and the presidency,
then they can change the number
of justices on the Supreme Court.
And the two parties can enter
into a never-ending cycle
of one-upsmanship where
they simply expand the Court
whenever it is convenient for them.
And in fact, former Harvard professor
and legal commentator Lawrence Tribe says,
"Obviously partisan Court-expansion
"to negate the votes of justices
whose views a party detests
"and whose legitimacy the party doubts
"could trigger a tit-for-tat spiral
"that would endanger the
Supreme Court's vital role
"in stabilizing the national
political and legal system."
So not only could the Supreme
Court expand and expand
any time that a political party
finds it convenient to do so,
but that very expansion might take away
some of the legitimacy
that people associate
with the Supreme Court's
rulings on different things
and remove some of the independence
that the Supreme Court is,
at least theoretically,
supposed to have.
So apart from simply adding
justices to the Supreme Court,
what else could be done to reform it?
Well, some people are arguing
for ending lifetime appointments.
This is Constitutionally suspect.
The Constitution says that the
judges of the Supreme Court
will stay in times of good behavior,
which generally has been interpreted
as being a lifetime appointment,
that the judge gets to
decide when he or she retires
and that there's nothing
that Congress can do
to force someone to early retirement
or to set term limits for the justices.
And there are many
places in federal service
where you want lifetime appointments
to be free from any kind
of political influence.
But some scholars suggest
that you can get around this
by simply rotating the judges through,
that someone can be appointed
to a term in the Supreme Court
and then relegated to one
of the federal circuits
after a certain number of
years have been served.
And there are pros and
cons to this approach.
Some argue that having
a lifetime appointment
means that justices
will be completely free
from political influence.
Others say that it simply
creates an incentive
for politicians to appoint
extremely young judges
who agree with you ideologically,
who will stay on the Court
for years and years and years
and then the other side simply
won't have an opportunity
to appoint somebody else.
But as we saw since the FDR days,
a lifetime appointment means
that some of the justices
will simply hold on forever,
until they actually might
pass away in office.
This is one of those areas
that regardless of what
the Constitution says,
there's not necessarily a right answer
in terms of term limits
for Supreme Court justices.
In fact, Justice Ginsburg
supported shorter terms
for Supreme Court justices.
The most popular suggestion
is limiting justices to 18 year terms.
This is a reform that seems
to have had bipartisan
support in the past,
but there are some
Constitutional problems with it.
Neither Congress nor the
president can fire judges
or force them out of office without cause,
however the Constitution provides
that justices shall hold their
offices during good behavior.
Good behavior has been interpreted
as conferring lifetime tenue on judges
and imposing term limits
would probably require a
Constitutional amendment.
Though some argue it's possible
that you could shuffle
a Supreme Court justice
off of the Supreme Court into
one of the federal circuits,
thus keeping them employed in
the federal system as a judge,
just not on the Supreme
Court for their life tenue.
But this also wouldn't solve
the politicization problem.
Battles over nominees would
probably still be fierce.
Some argue for a bigger Court
and a panel review system.
Vanderbilt professors Tracey
George and Chris Guthrie
propose that Congress change
the Court's institutional design.
Their idea is to increase the size
of the Supreme Court's membership
and remake in the image of
the US court of appeals.
First, they suggest of
increasing the size,
so it's approximately the same
size as the circuit courts,
which have around 13 judges per circuit.
Second, they propose that the Court
should hear almost all the cases in panels
rather than as a full Court,
which could at least double
and perhaps even triple
the Supreme Court's
decision making capacity,
which means that the Court
could decide even more cases.
Panels would be randomly selected,
so we would not know in advance
precisely which judges
would decide the case.
And third, Guthrie and George
say that the Court should
retain the authority
to grant and en banc review
in the small fraction of cases
that call for the Court
to speak as a full body.
And this is effectively how
the other federal circuits
operate all the time.
Theoretically, the
benefits of this proposal
include greater consistency
and clarity of in the law
in addition to, arguably,
less politicized nomination processes.
And still others argue
for Supreme Court reforms
that acknowledge that it is,
in fact, a political body.
Some argue for what's called
the Balance Bench approach,
a plan created by law professors
Daniel Epps and Ganesh Sitaraman.
Their plan in a nutshell
starts with 10 Supreme Court justices,
five would be affiliated
with the Democratic Party
and five with the Republican Party.
These 10 justices would then
select five additional justices
chosen from the current circuit,
or possibly district court judges.
These five circuit court judges
would need to be selected unanimously
by the 10 partisan judges
and they'd need to be
chosen two years in advance
for one year terms.
And if the justices fail to agree
on a slate of additional colleagues,
the Supreme Court would lack a quorum
and they could not hear
any cases for that year.
The Balanced Bench plan rests on the idea
that the partisan affiliated justices
would have to pick justices
would probably would never be
appointed to the Supreme Court
because they have views
that aren't easily traceable
to party affiliations.
And Epps and Sitaraman
believe that the justices
would select five people who
have a reputation for, quote,
"Fairness, independence, and centrism."
But of course, regardless
whatever benefits
this approach would have,
it's clearly unconstitutional,
so it would require a
Constitutional amendment
to actually implement.
But why let a silly little thing
like being unconstitutional
prevent it from being adopted?
But there's no dispute
that, for better or worse,
the system currently is
based largely on luck.
Some presidents might not get to appoint
a single Supreme Court justice
while others might appoint three or four.
But whether there are nine justices
on the Supreme Court or 900,
if you ever want to get
to the Supreme Court,
you've got to learn to write really well.
In fact, all lawyers have
to write really well.
And the best place to learn
anything is on Skillshare.
Which is why you would take
Sabaa Tahir's Skillshare class,
"Writing Authentic Fiction:
"How to Build a Believable Character."
Sabaa walks you through
her personal process
for crafting authentic
and believable characters.
It's packed with exercises,
prompts and tried and true techniques.
It's a class that will teach you
how to create real and nuanced characters
that feel like they could
walk right off the page.
Or you could take my friend
Thomas Frank's class,
"Real Productivity: How to
Build Habits that Last,"
because lawyers have to
be incredibly productive.
Thomas focuses on strengthening
your internal self-discipline,
assisting that self-discipline
with smart external systems,
and improving those habits over time
with regular reflection.
Skillshare, as I'm sure you know,
is one of the world's largest
online learning communities
that has tens of thousands
of classes on everything,
like illustration,
business, creative writing,
music, and productivity.
And the first 1,000 Legal Eagles
will get a free trial
of Skillshare Premium
when you click on the
link in the description.
Plus, after the trial ends,
Skillshare is still way more affordable
than most online learning
platforms out there,
with plans starting at
less than $10 per month.
So just click on the link below
to get a free trial
membership of Skillshare.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Do you think that the Supreme Court
should stay at nine justices
or should it be expanded?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other Real Law Reviews
talking about the crazy
stuff that's happening
in the Trump administration,
COVID-related legal issues
and all of the important
legal issues of the day.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.